[Applause]
the five actors nominated for actor in a
supporting role have been nominated a
combined 21 times four Academy Awards
and each has won at least once before
now I am no expert
having been here on this stage for the
first time last year but in my opinion
this may be one of the most impressive
field of actors to share this category
here are the nominees for actor in a
supporting role Alan Arkin Argo Robert
De Niro silver linings play
Philip Seymour Hoffman the master Tommy
Lee Jones ligand
Kristof bugs Django Unchained
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to Christophe box
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you so much mrs. DeNiro
mr. Arkin mr. Hoffmann and mr. Jones my
respect admire my unlimited braditude
goes to dr. King Schultz that is of
course to his creator and the creator of
his own inspiring world Quentin
Tarantino I thank Jamie Foxx and Leo
DiCaprio
Sam Jackson and Kerry Washington I thank
Harvey Weinstein Amy Pascal Stacy cher
Reginald Hudlin and pillar Siobhan
I think Adam Schweitzer Lisa Castella
and I thank my friends Jeff - now and
Bill Clark who saved my neck we
participated in in a hero's journey the
hero here being Quentin you scaled the
mountain because you're not afraid of it
you slay the dragon because you're not
afraid of it and you cross through fire
because it's worth it I borrowed my
character's words sorry couldn't resist
[Applause]